today we're going to turn these pennies
into gold sort of Okay Marina we're
going to put these pennies here into
this liquid then turn on the hot plate
and let the liquid heat up and now we
wait once it starts to boil safely
remove the liquid so the penny is silver
now how did that happen well we created
this solution with zinc and sodium
hydroxide and when you put the copper
pennies inside the liquid they turn
silver because zinc metal forms on the
surface of the copper to create the
silver colored material okay now let's
heat them up on the hot plate okay now
watch as the penny slowly changes
color that is so cool why did it happen
the heat from the hot plate is causing
the zinc to melt and mix with the copper
to form the brass alloy so does it mean
we have gold now yeah unfortunately no
it just happens when you add heat it
allows the two elements to mix and
creates a new alloy called brass which
just happens to look like gold